you've got a lot of cool friends though
right you hang out with a whole Cadre of
cool celebrities is that just well the I
do have some really cool friends here's
some of your friends let me see if I
give us the list aside from Willie
Nelson Paul McCartney really yeah yeah
well the last time I saw him I was we
went and stayed with them in the
Hamptons a few weeks ago look at that uh
hearing his wife Nancy are freaking
awesome do you jam with him at all no
but uh you know I I get to listen to him
play yeah yeah it's so cool because he
still always I mean he is all about the
music all the time and he's always you
know trying new things and you know
picking up the guitar how many hours out
of the day did you spend with Paul when
you're there
well I mean pretty much the whole day
whoa he taught me he taught me to sail
oh yeah on one of those little um
what do you call them Sun Sunfish yeah
and do you go wow I can't believe I'm
friends with Paul McCartney yeah I do
feel super lucky about it but uh
I really do and do they give you a key
to the house to come and go or do you
just well now we haven't reached quite
that stage
and what music is he playing when he's
does he does he ever do Maybe music
Maybe I'm Amazed like can you give
requests he does a lot of you know
Classics but the other day he played one
of my favorite songs it was incredible
man no it was Mother Nature song
and I'm like oh my God he's playing
Mother Nature son that's like a mantra
for me I've always I love that song
[Music]
all day long I'm sitting singing songs
for everyone
do you start singing with him I hope you
don't uh no I just I let him do it
foreign